[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact one stormy night in 1910 a group of
traveling musicians arrived at the city
of Riga on the Baltic Sea to fulfill a
constant engagement the weather was so
bad however that the conductor of the
orchestra tried to persuade the manager
of the hall to cancel the concert he
felt sure that no one would venture out
on such a rainy night the manager
refused to cancel but he did agree that
if no one turned up the orchestra could
leave early in order to catch the night
boat bound for Hill sinky in Finland
when the musicians arrived at the
concert hall they found only one person
sitting in the audience a stout old man
who smiled at everyone because of this
old man the musicians were forced to
play the entire concert and they were
unable to leave early to catch the boat
after the concert was over the old man
continued sitting in his seat thinking
that he was asleep and Asha notched his
shoulder
only then was it discovered that the old
man was dead the musicians have played
the entire concert for a dead man but
ironically in doing this that actually
saved their own lives for the boat that
they would have taken to Finland sank
that very night with a complete loss of
life the death of one man saved the
lives of many did you know friends that
the Bible teaches this same principle
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
72 and 97 call in and you can then put
your Bible question on the air and
together we'll search the scriptures to
find answers well before we get to the
phone lines I would like to invite you
to join me for a word of Prayer
via Father in Heaven once again we are
grateful for the opportunity to open up
your word and study together we
recognize that the Bible is your book
and in order for a person to correctly
understand it we need the leading of the
Holy Spirit so please be with us this
evening be with those who are listening
and guide us into a clearer
understanding of truth for we ask this
in Jesus name Amen
I open the program this evening by
sharing an amazing story that occurred
back in 1910 of a group of traveling
musicians who are actually wanting to
catch a boat that would actually save
them time to their next destination but
ended up having to do an entire concert
for one man and it turned out that that
old man before the end of the concert
actually passed away nevertheless by
them playing the concert they ended up
saving their own lives because the boat
that they would have taken sank well you
know we find an interesting principle in
the Bible both in the Old Testament and
also very clearly presented in the new
and that is by the
death of one man many lives are saved
and of course that one man that we're
talking about is none other than Jesus
Christ probably the most famous verse in
the Bible is John chapter 3 verse 16 and
this verse brings to light this
wonderful truth that says for God so
loved the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believes in
Him should not perish but have
everlasting life we also find the
Apostle Paul in Romans chapter 5 verse 8
saying something very similar but God
demonstrates his own love towards us in
that while we were still sinners Christ
died for us so there it is a glorious
truth found in the Bible that Jesus died
for us that his death takes the place of
our death he bore our sins died paying
the penalty for our transgressions and
by faith in Him we obtain forgiveness
and cleansing and hope of eternal life
now friends you might be wondering how
you can truly experience that wonderful
gift of salvation that comes through the
death of Jesus we have a book that we'd
like to make available to anyone who is
listening the book is entitled three
steps to heaven will actually go through
the basic steps that a person needs to
take in order to come into a saving
relationship with Jesus if you'd like to
receive this book it's free all you'll
have to do is call us on our resource
phone line and that number is 885 six
seven four seven once more that number
is 885 six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called three steps to
heaven we'll be happy to send it out to
anyone who calls and asks now if you're
outside of North America you're also
welcome to read the book you'll need to
just go to the amazing facts website
it's just amazing facts dot-com and you
can read the book for free online at our
online library that's amazing facts
comma dot o-r-g or call as for the book
we'll send it to you three steps to
heaven if you have a Bible question we
have just a few lines that are still
open it's a good time to pick up your
phone and give us a call the number
again is 804 sixty three seven two nine
seven 804 63 72 97
gonna go to our first caller this
evening we have Andrew listening in
Chattanooga Tennessee Andrew welcome to
Bible answers live hello pastor Russ and
thank you for taking my call
you're welcome so my my question is it
starts off with a kind of like a little
bit of me and what's going on with me
right now is I was grazing on the
nondenominational my entire life I was
always with the understanding that I
should follow the the Bible and the
commandments my parents always told me
to work hard and to enjoy and find
pleasure and everything that I do if I
wash dishes if I'm helping somebody else
to clean their house if I'm helping
somebody move any job that I've ever
taken I've always tried to find pleasure
in it to the point where somebody might
say that I'm a workaholic and I don't
find I don't find that work for me is
it's not a sacrifice I'll enjoy doing it
about two years ago somebody directed me
to the prophecy code and I started
watching it I learned about Sabbath
truth I learned about the fourth
commandment which I thought I had been
keeping my entire life but it turned out
to be that I hadn't and I'll tell you
what for the past two years I've tried
to keep the fourth commandment but I the
my least favorite day of the week is
Friday because the moment I wake up on
Friday I realize that there's only so
many hours left towards the Sabbath and
and I'm very frustrated very upset about
the start of the Sabbath simply because
I like working and I don't find it I
don't find work to be a sacrifice I
enjoy the type of work that I do okay so
your question then is how do you keep
the Sabbath when you really want to work
yeah okay all right well you know the
Sabbath commandment that you find of
course it's the fourth commandment in
the Ten Commandment says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
you're to Laban do all your work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the LORD
thy God in it you should not do any work
and then it goes on to talk about those
who are under your roof or those in your
sphere of influence
now when the Bible says you want to do
any work on the Sabbath that doesn't
mean you sit at home and do absolutely
nothing you don't want to be lazy on the
Sabbath but what the Bible means is you
lay aside your secular labor so the work
you do for an occupation or a paycheck
the work that you typically would do
maybe even when you're home and you're
relaxing and you want to do some work
around the yard or the garden or those
type of things those are the type of
work activities that you want to lay
aside that doesn't mean you don't do
anything on the Sabbath rather it means
that you dedicate those hours for
worshiping God fellowshipping with
like-minded believers it is also a day
when you can do the works of good as a
blessing to others in other words there
is nothing wrong matter of fact it's
encouraged on for example a Sabbath
afternoon to go visit someone maybe
there's someone in a nursing home that
you can visit with and pray with and
encourage it's a good day to to visit
the sect it's a good day to be involved
in sharing your faith or join a small
group Bible study so the Sabbath is not
a day of inactivity rather it is to be a
day of activity but activity that's
focused upon serving God and worshiping
him we lay aside our own interests our
own labors and focus upon those
particular areas that will be a blessing
to God and others okay does that help
answer a little bit yes it does I'm
trying to figure it out I know what
you're saying I don't like I don't like
just sitting at home doing nothing
myself but the Sabbath is the busiest
day of my week there's a lot happening
on Sabbath that's the day that I'm of
course worshiping in the morning and
then I like to visit with people in the
afternoon it's a great day for ministry
where I set aside my own interests and
focus upon blessing others and
ministering to them so try that I think
you'll find it a blessing you know we do
have a study guide dealing with the
Sabbath you might have seen it for those
who might be new to the Sabbath it's a
study guide called the last day in
history this is a wonderful truth that
many Christians are discovering and a
will be happy to send anyone the study
guide called a lost day in history the
number to call is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven thanks for
you
call an ex caller the behaved is calling
from looks like Toronto Canada and is
that Thomas that's calling what Thomas
yes good evening how are you doing
thanks for taking my call
you're welcome yes and your question
this evening um yes I was just wondering
if this is a teaching within
Christianity that I've heard but I've
never heard it I grew up as a mainstream
Christian but this is the the idea and
the significance of the number number
eight so for example Noah that Noah in
the New Testament is called the eighth
person right and there was eight people
from the earth
David was the eighth son of Jesse
Abraham covenant had eight components to
it he had three animals had to be cut in
half and two birds
there was eight flames in the temple
that had to be lit continually so what
I'm saying is that there's a I've never
heard this before but someone shared
this with me that when you take Jesus's
name in the Greek New Testament written
in Greek and you add up those Greek
letters because they have a numerical
value it comes to 888 and I'm just
wondering on the significance of Jesus
being 888 and all these other parallels
of the eighth day like circumcision and
the sacrificial animals were only
acceptable on the eighth day sure well
you know in the Bible numbers are
significant especially when you get to
prophetic books for example Daniel and
revelation and even some of the the
Minor Prophets numbers do have
significance just to run through the the
key numbers I think you're aware that
the number one in the Bible represents
unity of purpose the number two is often
associated with the word of God
sometimes referred to as the law and the
prophets the number three is often
associated with the Godhead the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit the number
four is a number that's often associated
with the world or the earth you've got
the four points of the compass north
south east and west and the number four
is often associated with the world the
number five is typically connected with
doctrine or teaching and the reason for
that is the first five books of Moses
referred to as the law other were five
books and that was called doctrinal
it was foundational to the Jew and also
to the Christians understanding of God's
will the number six often associated
with man
it's man's number is created on the
sixth day of the week the number seven
is significant because that's God's
number represents perfectional
completion the number eight in the Bible
is interesting it's often associated
with a remnant being delivered and you
gave some examples of that know Andy's
family 8 were delivered from the flood
it's interesting the parallel you did
with the name of Jesus in the original
Greek that's not something that I've
actually researched and looked up but 8
is often associated with a remnant
bringing through deliverance or
salvation and you could probably see
some examples of that not a whole lot of
significance the number 9 in the Bible
but 10 is very significant that of
course represents the ten commandments
the number 11 not a whole lot of
significance but 12 represents God's
people the 12 tribes of the Old
Testament twelve apostles of the new and
then the next big number that's
significant is the number forty which
represents the time of trial or testing
it rained for 40 days and 40 nights
children of Israel in the wilderness for
40 years
Christ fasted for 40 days in the
wilderness so when you look at all of
the significance of those numbers yes
eight is part of that cluster of numbers
that is significant in that it often has
to do with the remnant being delivered
or cold out or saved could I ask just
like something else to ask you no
comparison sure so like um what I kind
of understand is also not only because
God created everything so he gave us the
Bible but he also spoke creation into
being right yes so like you said about
twelve sons Twelve Apostles there's also
12 months there was also two to two
stacks of six loaves of showbread in the
temple right yes and what creation has
this 12 hours of daylight 12 hours of
night 12 months of the year and if this
is what they pointed out to me so the
oat the two numbers that God gave if
people then knew about Jesus being a tea
date and and the numbers like fix it
what you like you said is a number of
sin the man of unrighteousness or sin
which the fall of
but in the periodic table you have both
those numbers and I'll tell you why
oxygen is number eight on the periodic
table and it has eight electrons eight
protons and eight neutrons and carbon is
number six on the periodic table and it
has six electrons six protons and six
neutrons and carbon is the same as
carbon is the same it does right it's
the element of life well you know that's
a great thought and probably there's a
lot more than one could study with those
numbers it's probably exhaustless if you
look at these different numbers and look
at some of the parallels that you have
in the Bible and very interesting it's a
great study for those who are listening
you might not be familiar with the
numbers in the Bible there is if you go
to the amazing facts website and you
type in their Bible numbers you'll
probably see we have a resource there
that'll quickly go through the numbers
with their meaning as well as their
biblical reference and I think Thomas
you'll enjoy that as well sounds like
you've done quite a bit of studying with
numbers so thanks for your call we
appreciate it next quarter that we have
is dawn and he's listening from Brandon
Florida don't welcome to the program
hello
my question is in John chapter 20 verse
17 Mary encounters the Risen Jesus and I
guess he goes to grab hold of them and
this tozer do not cling to me for I have
not ascended to my father in heaven yes
now in Jesus a time ascends to his
father is that the exact time in
Revelations 5 that he receives the
scroll okay good question my fact I just
I was just actually teaching on that
this this past weekend just for those
who might be not familiar with the
passage you're referring to you're
talking about an experience that
occurred after the resurrection of Jesus
where Mary was at this is not Mary the
mother of Jesus this is Mary Magdalene
she was at the tomb it was empty because
Christ had risen from the dead there
were some other disciples that had been
there they had seen the empty tomb and
they had gone back to Jerusalem to tell
the other disciples about it but Mary
lingered there at the tomb and she
thought it was the gardener that she met
and she had been weeping and she said if
you can tell me where they have moved
his body please let me know
and then Jesus revealed himself and just
said her name Mary and then would
actually realized this is the risen
Christ she fell at his feet and clung to
him jesus said do not cling to me or do
not detain me would be another word that
you could use I have not yet ascended to
my father in heaven
it appears that Jesus then after that
encounter with Mary ascended to his
father in heaven and received from the
father the assurance that his sacrifice
was sufficient that indeed the atoning
sacrifice was enough to provide
forgiveness and cleansing and salvation
for those who believed in him and then
later that same day Jesus appears to the
disciples in the upper room and he's on
and off with them for about the next
forty days and then it seems at the end
of that time period is the official
ascension of Jesus where he speaks to
these disciples he says I will come back
again and he has his final Commission to
the disciples then he ascends to heaven
and shortly after that the Holy Spirit
comes upon the disciples so what we find
described in Revelation chapter five I
think would relate more to his official
ascending up to heaven when he begins
his work as our high priest in heaven
ministering on behalf of God's people
and the reason I say that is because in
Revelation 5 you'll notice and that
Jesus takes a scroll out of the father's
hand that is sealed with seven seals and
he begins to open up those seals and
different events begin to occur
throughout the Christian era throughout
the Christian history so a number of
scholars feel that revelation chapter
five would be the official beginning of
Christ as a high priest in heaven okay
that makes sense
because when he ascended to heaven first
time after Mary encountered him then he
wouldn't have time to start his work yet
correct it was after the forty days and
then he ascended and then he started his
work as the high priests which meant
opening up the scroll correct
opening up the seals and the scroll and
of course the scroll ends up being the
Lamb's Book of Life and then you have
the rest of Revelation playing out so a
number of scholars see apart
with Christ's officially beginning is
high priestly ministry in revelation 5
alright oh thank you so much
clears it up for me I pray thank you for
your question good question
next caller there we have is Frank and
he's listening in Alabama Frank welcome
to the program hi yes is it possible to
be guilty of committing adultery just by
having too much companionship with
someone even if there's no sexual
involvement whatsoever well the Bible
says that the marriage relationship is
more than just physical intimacy but
it's also emotional intimacy that's why
Jesus said if you look at a woman and
lust after you're guilty of committing
adultery in your heart I think any
married person needs to be careful with
how much time they spend with you know
someone other than their spouse of the
opposite sex there is a principle of
life that often the company of one that
you enjoy being with multiplied by the
amount of time spent with that person
will naturally lead to some kind of
emotional connection so I think as
Christians we need to be particularly
the Bible tells us to avoid the
appearance of evil even if there might
not be any physical contact that is
inappropriate if our affections are
placed upon another other than our
spouse especially romantic affections
that is something that the Bible warns
us to be aware of and stay away from
okay so I know what you're saying would
it actually bear the title of committing
the adultery in God's eyes I'm history
is there possibility I realize just a
little bit of friendly talk with
someone's not gonna not going to be in
that category but I mean is that the
possibility if there's no just take too
much time away from your spouse or
something like that just for
companionship with someone else that
could we then fall in that category well
you know that it could I think if it
attracts your your heart and your
feelings and your attention yeah I think
we need to be careful a marriage the
marriage covenant these sacred needs to
be number one in our life our affections
need to be first and foremost to our
spouse
and you know if somebody's wondering
maybe I'm spending just a little too
much time with my secretary or maybe you
know I'm traveling with somebody at work
or a friend or someone I've known for
many years one of the things one could
do is ask their spouse and say you know
what I want to make sure that you're not
feeling uncomfortable what do you advise
and usually the spouse will be honest
and say you know what I you're probably
spending too much time with him or her
so I think we need to respect our spouse
and they wishes as well that is an
excellent idea considering this you know
it is harder to find the exact
borderline I really appreciate your
input on that all right well thank you
for your call Frank we appreciate that
and our next caller that we have is
Gustavo listening from New York Gustavo
welcome to the program doing well and
your question this evening I'm in the
military and I just I just wanted to
know is it wrong to be in the military
even if they require you to work on
service during a deployment okay well
you know that is a that is a very
important and good question are there
faithful Christians are serving the
m'allister military yes
have there been faithful Sabbath keepers
that have served in the military yes all
the way back from World War two
a very famous Sabbath keeper was Desmond
Doss who served in the military as a
medic he refused to carry a gun he
didn't want to take life but he felt
that it was very appropriate for him to
try and heal and help those who were
injured and so he was a very famous
medic in World War two however having
said that to be a Sabbath keeper in the
military does often result in a trying
of your faith it is difficult and there
are many experiences where people have
had their faith challenged and even
faced opposition because those that they
are working with or working for don't
understand their commitment now
fortunately in the United States there
are exceptions that are made for those
who want to keep the seventh-day Sabbath
and it's something that one needs to be
upfront with and you need to communicate
with your supervisors in some emergency
situations if you're working especially
in the medical arena there are people
who have to be taken care of on the
Sabbath like a doctor or nurse you know
of course that is appropriate as well
one thing I would add though is if we
gonna ask for privileges on the Sabbath
to worship we need to be consistent in
that the problem is if there is a
soldier who doesn't keep the Sabbath and
then wants to keep the Sabbath and then
he doesn't keep the Sabbath then he
wants to keep the Sabbath there's a lack
of consistency and that causes
additional hardship and trials in the
military so being faithful with your
conviction is very important right from
the very beginning all right okay thank
you practice you answered my question
all right thank you for your call next
caller that we have is Billy listening
from North Carolina Billy welcome to the
program thank you sir
my question is is the return of tithes
on Social Security earnings and it's my
understanding the Social Security
withholding taxes withheld from your
paycheck and then put into the Social
Security Fund and your employer also
matches that amount and it is put into
the fund
now when you retire and you start
receiving benefits your yeah you should
pay the tithe on your contributions but
do you pay tithe on the employers
contribution that's put it into the fund
for you well the principle that you find
in the Bible is we pay a tithe on our
increase so whether that's an increase
that we earn or whether that's an
increase that is given to us by our
employee it's still a increase now
specifically on Social Security some
folks will pay their tithe on their
gross that they receive every month
before the deductions are taken out for
retirement and Social Security and some
of these things they pay on the on the
gross amount the big amount and then
they've already
highest type a they tithe for those
deductions and when they do retire they
receive their their Social Security
often they will pay an offering but they
wouldn't necessarily pay the tithe
because they've already paid on the
tithe although I do know folks who have
paid on the growth of their salary and
then after they retire they still
continue to pay atai it even on their
social security because they believe
that you can't out bless God and of
course we know of many experiences we
got as blessed people who have been
generous in their giving to the cause of
God not only with their tithe but also
what they offering so you know that's
the principle that we have in the Bible
and I think individually one needs to
pray and say Lord how do you want me to
respond and deal with the issue of
tithing and offering and giving Billy we
want to thank you for your call you can
hear me coming up on a break and friends
we're not done we're just taking a short
break and we'll be back with more Bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
Tarara as the come through your mail the
other day you were looking through my
watch and I found a way to can say pick
on your taxes now that you are 17 1/2
years old you commit turnable donations
to amazing facts and I are incredible
rollover is a win-win for you and the
Lord's work first it satisfies your
minimum distribution it reduces your
taxable income it is not subject to the
50% deduction limit and your gift helps
amazing facts bring people to Jesus call
amazing facts today to see how we can
help you get the most out of your IRA
the number to dial is 800 436 to 695 or
visit my legacy Tom Mason facts org for
over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we build churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming a ministry partner please
visit our website at amazing facts dot
o-r-g
[Music]
if you've missed any of our amazing
facts programs visit our website at
amazing facts org there you'll find an
archive of all our television and radio
programs including amazing facts
presents one location so many
possibilities amazing facts org every
bible question you have answered moves
you one step closer to the fullness of
god's will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
have a number of callers waiting so
we're gonna go to our next caller
we have Lola listening from North
Carolina
Lola welcome to the program good evening
pastor my question what are we supposed
to do with the left over emblems for the
communion service some say they need to
be buried or burned some say you can
simply throw them away what do we do
with him all right well first of all I
wouldn't throw them away I wouldn't just
dump them in the garbage that seems a
little bit it doesn't seem like the
appropriate way to get rid of the
leftover communion bread it does
represent something it's a symbol
of the body of Christ and the grape
juice the atoning blood of Christ and we
want to recognize just like you wouldn't
want to treat the Bible as any common
book so you wouldn't want to treat the
grape juice and and the communion bread
that's been blessed just like any type
of bread or juice so typically most
churches the appropriate way to deal
with that is to bury the leftovers or in
some cases they'll place it in if they
have if it's wintertime and they have a
fire going or something like that it's
appropriate to put it there as well most
times in our situation we will have
somebody bury the bread and the grape
juice at home okay thank you thank you
all right you're welcome thank you for
your call next caller that we have is
David listening in Michigan David
welcome to the program hello yes hi
David you're on the air
hi Pastor Ross it's a purpose to be
speaking with you well thanks for your
call and your question this evening I
thought my question is I was reading in
John's Gospel chapter one today again
and John the Baptist replied to some
messengers who were sent from Jerusalem
I'm asking who are you and he denied
three times he said I'm not Elijah he
said I'm not the Christ and I'm not the
Prophet so my question is why did John
the Baptist deny that he was Elijah when
in Matthew chapter 11 after John the
Baptist who was imprisoned at that time
had sent some of his disciples to Jesus
to ask him the question are you the
Christ or are we to look for someone
else and at that time Jesus had revealed
and said if you will receive it John the
Baptist actually was Elijah so why would
John the Baptist not know and deny that
he was Elijah good question well first
of all John the Baptist wasn't Elijah
the Elijah that ascended up to heaven
the Elijah that sent it to heaven of
course was a great prophet of the Old
Testament it becomes a symbol of a
special prophetic blessing that would be
given prior to the coming of Jesus the
first coming but also a special
outpouring of the Holy Spirit and
prophetic gift given before the second
coming of Jesus so when the religious
leaders asked John are you Elijah they
weren't thinking about the spirit or
power rather they were looking for
something that they could use against
him something to hinder his work in his
ministry the religious leaders believed
that the literal Elijah would come down
from heaven and John the Baptist saying
no I'm not the literal Elijah that I
sent it up to heaven but I am the one
preparing the way for the coming of
Christ that's why when Jesus spoke of
this to his disciples he said if you can
receive this he is or this prophecy is
referencing to Elijah meaning John the
Baptist came in the spirit and the power
of Elijah now the reason the religious
leaders thought that Elijah would come
down is because of the prophecy in
Malachi chapter 4 verse 5 that says a
behold I will send you Elijah the
Prophet before the coming of the Great
and dreadful day of the Lord
now the religious leaders looked at that
and they were interpreting that prophecy
in their day meaning that when the
Messiah would come he would establish an
earthly Kingdom because they referred to
the Great and dreadful day of the Lord
and in order for them to be set straight
in their understanding of Christ's
mission as well as John the Baptist John
said no I'm not that Elijah I'm not the
one that you think I am jesus said he
came in the spirit and power of Elijah
he was that Elijah but according to
Malachi chapter 4 verse 5 there will be
a special outpouring of the Holy Spirit
again and the prophetic gift revived
before the great and dreadful day of the
Lord there would be the second coming in
judgment does that help a little bit
David and that helps a little bit so
you're saying that there is yet to be
another appearance of the spirit and
power of Elijah or that's happening now
you know what I think it's gonna grow
all the way through to the end we know
that before Jesus comes there is another
special outpouring of the Holy Spirit as
it was at Pentecost there will be
miracles wrought the the gospel is gonna
be preached around the world the
prophecy in Malachi says before the
coming of the Great and dreadful day of
the Lord and we know that's not
referring to the first coming of Christ
although it had a partial application it
really does refer to the second coming
of Christ okay that helps a little bit I
just thought it was true
that Jesus said he had come in the
spirit of Elijah but yet John Baptist
stilled and acknowledged that in any
wise to those leaders who came to him I
think and as I said earlier probably
because John knew that they were trying
to use whatever John would say against
him to try and Hindi's work ok ok so he
he answered wisely ok so that's hard all
right well thank you David good question
thank you for the help all right next
caller that we have is Roger listening
in Colorado
Roger welcome to Bible answers live
thank you pastor ROG I've got an
interesting question I've heard this a
few other times and I can't quite find
it in the Bible or what it refers to
there was somebody that said there were
five lands do you know what they might
be talking about somebody said this was
heard in a seminar by Pastor dark and
the question is there were five Lambs as
in the animal lands L AM B yeah what
would the five Lambs be representing
okay well if you're looking in the book
of Revelation how many times the word
lamb appears it's more than five the
first reference that we have of the word
lamb in Revelation there's actually a
lot of I'm just looking at it hearing my
computer the first reference is
Revelation 5:6 and it goes all the way
through you have multiple references all
the way to revelation 22 verse 3 where
you have the word lamb used each of the
times the word lamb is used as a
reference to Jesus Jesus is described as
the lamb and of course the reason he's
described as the lamb is because the
lamb was an animal useful sacrifice in
the Old Testament it was a sacrifice for
sin Jesus is the Lamb of God it's John
the Baptist said when Jesus was baptized
he takes away the sins of the world
so in Revelation it's emphasizing the
fact that Jesus is the savior he's the
lamb he died in order to forgive
thank you that helped me quite a bit in
our understand also the lamb was the
first thing actually killed on the face
of the earth with Adam and Eve if I'm
not mistaken
well the Bible says that after Adam and
Eve sinned of course they made for
themselves fig leaf coverings and that
was not sufficient so God provided them
tunics of skin meaning that an animal
was sacrificed in order for them to have
that it could very well have been a land
sacrificed lambs were used throughout
the Old Testament for sacrifice along
with others but lambs also used okay
thank you very much you answered a lot
of questions for me all right well thank
you for your pastor Russ thank you for
your call Roger appreciate it thank you
bye bye bye bye
we've got Nancy who is listening from
Ohio Nancy welcome to the program thank
you Pastor I was I'm so glad I got to
pick you on the show I was hoping I
wouldn't be cut off but I've always been
raised as a Christian that once you
receive salvation once you take part is
your savior that the gift of salvation
is permanent it's eternal
you can't lose it I heard a sermon just
recently tonight where a minister was
saying that Christians can fall from
grace and be removed from the book of
life
and lose their salvation and it really
shook me up the scripture he was talking
about with were Christians can fall from
grace I always interpreted that as
someone who became a Christian the
minute they actually turned their back
and on the faith they turned it back on
Christianity they like walk away from
the faith that that to me was falling
from grace but he made it sound like
even if you mess up you sin you whatever
you fall from grace you're gonna lose
your salvation and I just wanted to get
your interpretation on that yeah
absolutely you know when a person comes
to God and they confess their sins and
they surrendered their life to Jesus
there is no doubt according to the Bible
that we are forgiven of our sins the
Holy Spirit then begins to work in our
hearts and lives and we're saved we've
received Jesus as our personal Savior
but after we receive him as our Savior
we need to maintain a faith relationship
with Jesus it's not good enough just to
call yourself a Christian and yet be
disconnected from Christ Jesus says many
will say to me in that day Lord Lord did
we not prophesy in your name and cast
out Devils and do all kinds of miracles
then Jesus will say I never knew you
depart from me he workers of iniquity so
just having a name saying well I'm a
Christian but not having a living faith
connection with Jesus is not going to
save anyone
now that doesn't mean that if you know
we're a Christian we love the Lord but
we are tempted and we make a mistake and
we fall and we are convicted of that sin
it doesn't mean the minute we
soon we lost rather means when that
conviction comes we need to turn to the
Lord and say Lord please forgive me
please give me the grace and the
strength to resist and overcome that's
staying in a saving relationship with
Jesus but if we neglect that
relationship if we turn away from Christ
if we don't communicate with him through
prayer if you don't spend time in his
word our hearts begin to grow cold they
begin to grow hard and we lose that
faith connection with Christ to the
point where we have no interest in
spiritual things we're not interested in
what Jesus wants to do for us and we
have a spirit of rebellion
that's what the Bible warns us about
it's sometimes referred to as the
unpardonable sin it's a sin where there
is no desire to be repented and that's
something that Christians need to make
sure that we we don't do we want to stay
connected to Christ and as long as we do
we're safe we're saved
we're in his hands well that's really
thank you does that help Nancy yes yeah
you know like it's right I've been a
Christian for many many years and this
is this was first time I really heard of
anyone say that and as much as I try to
walk in a you know and God willing with
a Christian life and you know live in
faith you know I messed up time to time
you know and I just didn't know like if
that was going to put me you know I like
being in that book I don't want to
absolutely that's why we have the Holy
Spirit that brings conviction and when
we are convicted that we are doing
something out of harmony with God's will
and we recognize that and we go to God
and repaint it to me ask for forgiveness
but that means the Holy Spirit is
working on us and we in that saving
relationship with God so just because a
person sins it doesn't mean that God
abandons us rather it means that we need
to realize a need for him and need to
rely upon him more and have a stronger
faith exactly yes thank you so much
pastor I can't sleep now thank you
okay thank you for your call names that
we appreciate it
bye-bye our next call of the behaved is
calling from Alabama we have Maria Maria
welcome to the program
thank you thank you so much god bless
you this evening I have a question if
you're a Christian you've been saved you
do truly believe and when you die when
you close your eyes do you go from death
to life do you when you die do you wake
up with Jesus or do you are you in a
sleep do you sleep very good question
now the Bible says that flesh and blood
cannot inherit the kingdom we also know
that when Jesus comes the second time
that he's going to change our mortal
bodies and make them immortal and we
also know that there's going to be a
glorious resurrection when Jesus comes
and the dating Christ will be raised
first that's first there's a long in
chapter 4 so the reward of the redeemed
occur at the second coming of Christ
when a person dies and they breathe
their last breath and they think their
last thought and they die the very next
conscious thought that they will have is
the second coming of Jesus because
they'll be resurrected from the dead
now someone might be dead for 10 years
or a hundred years or 2,000 years but to
them the moment they die the very next
thought they have is the second coming
of Jesus because in death there is no
time we're not aware of what's happening
our the Bible sometimes license death to
asleep a dreamless sleep so for the
believer the moment you close your eyes
in death the very next thing you know
Jesus is coming and you resurrected a
lot of time might have passed between
your death and your resurrection but
you're unaware of that and so that's why
Paul says to be absent from the body is
to be present with the Lord
the moment we die the very next thing we
know is we have our new bodies and we
are resurrected Jesus is coming and
forever we're with the Lord hallelujah
Jesus thank you thank you so much you're
welcome and thank you Maria for your
call you know we do have a lesson that
you might find interesting
dealing with the subject of what happens
when a person dies it's called are the
dead really
it's an amazing fact study guide and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks our resource phone
line the phone line is 808 three five
six seven four seven again it's 808
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the study guide called
all the dead really dead and it talks
about this subject on what the Bible
teaches on it
did you know amazing facts has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 for two hundred fifty
seven thousand that's one eight four
four two one five seven thousand our
next call of the behalf is Betty and
she's listening for Michigan baby
welcome to the program hi hi thanks for
your cold how are you very good thank
you your question Betty I've been going
to an Apostolic Church and they said
that you have to be baptized in Jesus
name and speaking songs for the evidence
of having the holy spirit in order to go
to heaven and I've been baptized in
Jesus name about 26 years ago but I've
never spoken talk okay and your question
is do you have to speak in tongues in
order to be saved or as an evidence that
you have the Holy Spirit in you yes in
order to be saved and go to heaven
okay the short answer is no matter of
fact there's a misunderstanding today
amongst some Christians with reference
to what it means to speak in tongues
speaking in tongues is one of the gifts
of the Holy Spirit it's given for the
furtherance of the gospel the first
thing we need to understand is that the
word tongues means language so the first
manifestation of the gift of tongues to
be read about is in the book of Acts
it's when there were people from all
different countries gathered in
Jerusalem and the Holy Spirit came upon
the disciples and they got up and they
preached in these different languages
that people were able to hear the gospel
preached to them in their own tongue or
in their own language there are some
experiences and I know some missionaries
who had supernatural abilities to speak
a language that they had not learned for
the purpose of communicating the gospel
to other people that's what the gift of
tongues
really means do you have to speak in an
unknown language or a language you have
not learned as evidence that you have
the Holy Spirit no the evidence of the
Holy Spirit for the Christian isn't the
gifts of the Spirit it's the fruit of
the Spirit now the fruit of the Spirit
is love and joy and peace and patience
long-suffering gentleness meekness
self-control that's evidence that the
Holy Spirit is working in a person's
heart not the gift you see the Holy
Spirit will give gifts based upon the
needs of the church the son the gift of
healing to son the gift of speaking a
language that they have not learned in
others there's the gift of
administration or leadership some have
the gift of music so the Holy Spirit
gives gifts as needed in the church but
evidence of the Holy Spirit in the life
of the believer is the fruit of the
Spirit not the gifts of the Spirit does
that make sense Betty
yes so what I have to be baptized in
Jesus name only or well the Bible says
when we baptize in the name of Jesus in
the name of the Father Son and Holy
Spirit that we are forgiven and that the
Holy Spirit begins to work within us
there is no need for some manifestation
of some kind of speaking in tongues as a
testimony that we have the Holy Spirit
that's not taught in the New Testament
that's not taught anyway in the Bible
actually you know Betty we have a book
that I think you'd really enjoy reading
because it's an important subject and a
lot of people have questions about it
the book is simply called understanding
tongues and we'll be happy to send it to
you for free Betty or anyone wanting to
learn more about this there is some
confusion I think Christianity today
about the gift of tongues the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and as for the book
called understanding tongues on more
time it's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven asked for the book
understanding tongues we'll be happy to
send that out to anyone who calls and
asks we have Aaron who is listening in
Arizona
Aaron welcome to the program hi Pat the
Russ thank you for taking my call you're
welcome
my question is so how do I confront
pastors or youth leaders about bringing
worldly music into the church or some
youth event okay well you know that can
be
Challenge there there are some sometimes
in the church that think that in order
and they'd sincere in their thinking but
in order to try and reach the youth we
need to some I use the music that the
world is using to entertain the youth
but I think as Christians we need to be
careful to adopt worldly methods to try
and reach heavenly ends it doesn't
always work that way
I've often had people that were very
much into worldly music that became
Christians and the more their faith grew
the more they're tasteful music changed
away from the style of music that they
were very much involved with in the
world to a more heavenly style you might
say or or more a biblically based form
of worship and music so yes it can be a
challenge I found probably if there is
someone in the church that is advocating
these worldly music in the church one of
the best things to do is to share your
own personal experience or a testimony
of someone that you know who became a
Christian and came out of that style of
music and they recognized that they were
looking for something different and
better in the church they weren't just
looking for the same style of worship or
the same style of music that they had in
the world okay but it is a delicate
subject and I think one needs to go in
here with much prayer but I think a
personal testimony is still one of the
more powerful ways of helping people
understand that we don't have to try and
copy the world to evangelize especially
reach the youth okay thank you all right
Thank You Aaron appreciate your call our
next caller that we have is Jay
listening I think it's in Maryland Jay
welcome to the program hello how you
doing doing well and your question this
evening okay my question is you kind of
answered part of it earlier but my other
part is I was reading about the guys in
the Bible okay the tribes got together
and he took and told the guys hey look
go look at the promised land and he said
12-lead
from each try right one liter from each
of the tribes yes okay so they went they
looked at the land and they came back
and one of them was like we can take
them you know through God's will never
yeah and which means that two of them
said we can go up and take the land and
the other ten said no we can't we
grasshoppers and they Giants we can't go
okay in the midst of that right yeah
when when they explained that to the
people it said the people cried tore
their shirts right mhm and they wanted
to stone them who did they want to stone
they wanted to stone Moses and Aaron
they blamed Moses and Aaron first of all
it was a lack of faith on their part
even though the two spies came back
Joshua and Caleb they said if God is
with us we can take this land and they
told how beautiful the land is all the
spies agreed that it was a wonderful
land they brought back fruit from the
land but the people instead of
exercising faith and believing what
Aaron and Moses was encouraging them to
do along with the two spies that had
that were there they decided to reject
the two spies and go along with the
opinion of the ten spies and as a result
they got so angry they said we want a
stone they wanted to stone Aaron and
Moses and God had to interpose on their
behalf because the other got so angry
and as a result of that lack of faith in
me badly and the children of Israel
ended up wandering in the wilderness for
another forty years before they were
allowed to enter into the Promised Land
and the only two that entered into the
Promised Land Moses didn't Aaron didn't
but Joshua and Caleb the two spies that
came back and said we can take the land
they're the only two of those above 20
that were able to enter into the
Promised Land okay all right um can I
ask another quick quick question yeah
okay um how do you know you saved you
know I remember when I felt I was saved
and I live in the hood right so I got a
lot of things as far as music the
internet everything trying to come
against me but I remember when I got
saved when I was younger but also know
now when that
: comes when I something bad or I'm
about to do something bad or something
says hey believe don't do that don't
smoke that come on drink that don't go
with them and am I still stayed well you
know that's a testimony the Holy Spirit
is working upon you you know if we keep
connected to God that doesn't mean we
won't ever sin but when we do sin we
repent of that sin and we recognize that
need of Jesus and we say please Lord
forgive me I can't do anything without
you and as long as we stay connected to
Christ you know spend time in the word
spend time on your knees in prayer allow
the Holy Spirit to keep convicting you
and leading and guiding you we need not
fear whether or not be saved if we stay
connected to Jesus and He will work his
will within us the problem is when we
walk away from Jesus and we ignore him
and we neglect prayer I mean they let
the study of his word we're walking down
a path where our hearts can get hotter
and we can even spiritually speaking
grow deaf to hearing the Holy Spirit
speak to us and we don't want that
that's not a good place to be for anyone
how do I not want to say grieve the Holy
Spirit like I say I can make the Holy
Spirit mad or grieving where you walk
away from me well the Holy Spirit you
know I don't want to do that all right
well the Holy Spirit is very consistent
and very persistent in trying to keep us
it's not like we offend God one time and
he leaves us know God is long-suffering
not willing that any should perish the
Bible says so I think the key for us as
Christians is keep connected to God
spend some time in his word spend time
in prayer exercise faith in Him believe
his word believe that he's there to help
you believe that he loves you believe
that he'll work his will in you and as
our faith grows our confidence in him
grows so we begin to see more and more
of him working in our hearts and lives
so don't get discouraged the devil wants
you to get discouraged keep taking God
at His Word keep trusting in him
thank you so much that means so much to
me thank you
alright well god bless EJ our friends as
you can hear we hear music playing in
the background and we've come to the end
of this edition of Bible answers live we
want to thank you for calling and if we
didn't get to your call today call us
next week god bless thank you for
listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dhic index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
[Music]
what if you could know the future of
what you do what would you change to see
the future you must understand the past
Alexander the Great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
a hundred and fifty years in advance
Cyrus had been named
Nebuchadnezzar built the city as a
showcase to the entire world
Rome was violent they were ruthless
they were determined
this intriguing documentary posted by
pastor Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time an
extraordinary adventure through the
Bible's most amazing fulfilled
prophecies are you ready this at AF
bookstore com for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners
carrying individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming a ministry partner please
visit our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 macing fax o RG